[Music]
everybody
comes around the side with the poison
trap of all things gonna be taken up
down i believe
now mccoy gets another one on the enemy
can they turn this on its head cory's
got the high ground to take the pawn
shop
gets a dead in midair gets the head
shuttle to becco as well beautiful stuff
from corey
the next one is corey also an overwatch
world cup winner with team usa
one of the stars of the league decided
i'm done i'm going to valerie
you has been used in exchange for that
by cory corey looks like he's holding
that angle
hasn't popped out yet because he's still
oh my god she's able to get two
guys give him the eighth baby
what a huge round for face clan
finding success as a pro player in any
esport
is a pretty rare feat simple he needs a
multi-kill
first found twist aggressing they have
to double peek he's getting his shots
he's hitting another one
simple oh simple that's unbelievable
what in his name number one in the game
he's done it again
but a successful career in two different
games is almost unheard of
unless of course we're talking about
valorant
carlos tries he does all that he can but
it's simply not enough against a hundred
thieves a hundred thieves they've done
it they are your first strike
north america champions ever since its
release
valar has become a sort of hub for
former overwatch and cs go players who
are looking for a second chance at glory
i think if anything overwatch was just
like a stepping stone
to get here where i am now because now
i'm at i just feel at home man i'm
playing a game that's like a hybrid of
like cs
and overwatch both established
contenders and washed up pros left their
original games in droves to form new
teams and try their luck in a brand new
esport
but few players can say they've had the
transition that corey has had
you'll have it at some point it's only
around number seven oh and a showstopper
in his overwatch league days cory was
considered an elite player
he comes around the side with a poison
trap of all things gonna be taken up
down high court
now mccoy gets another one on the envy
his incredible skills earned him a
reputation as one of the aim gods of
overwatch
can they turn this on its head corey's
got the high ground he's taking pot
shots
checks they dead in midair it's the
headshot on the mecco as well beautiful
stuff from corey and in 2019 he helped
team usa win gold and bring home the
overwatch world cup
team usa they're gonna get back on and
touch supercharger from super corey's
tracer
what a nuisance burns elsa down and now
he's looking for more kio he's in deep
travel at just 20 years old corey was at
the top of his game
finally after four years three years of
heartbreak
for the very first time
[Applause]
but then the meta shifted and all of a
sudden
things weren't exactly favorable for his
beloved dps characters like widowmaker
and tracer
why would i play a strict damage dealer
like tracer for example
uh why would i play a strict damage
dealer or mccree or widow or whatever
when i can play a hero that is now kind
of damaged
uh like mei so i can still click heads
with the icicle i can freeze people
i have a wall and i have a massive aoe
ult that [ __ ] everybody up in a 10 mile
radius like
why am i going to play a damage dealer
when i can do that dps players were
dropping like flies
and corey joined a number of other big
names who decided to leave the overwatch
pro scene
cory was obviously an incredible
overwatch player and
earlier in his career he actually wanted
to go pro in cs go
so his next move made sense he was going
to try his hand
at valorant
riot's shooter seemed like the perfect
combination of the two games that corey
loved
it looks like cs go with overwatch
ultimates
but the thing is many people thought
that games like overwatch and valerian
didn't take as much skill as cs go
and in their minds any overwatch player
trying to play valrant could never match
up to anybody who used to play cs go for
a living
the skill sealing and the potential is a
lot lower than a game like
counter-strike
right so azk brack skadoodle
right legends insane
but they're capped they're capped right
so everybody else is going to be on
their level
i think people were just looking like a
lot of these players were just looking
at overwatch and being like yeah like
oh like you play reinhardt or something
you know what i mean
but that's not the case you know there's
actually a lot of aim that goes into it
and that's why
um we are like pretty like baze is
pretty much like one of the most
mechanically gifted
teams out there you know like none of us
are tank players
so if valorent was going to be the arena
where former overwatch and cs go players
duked it out
the winner seemed obvious except corey
was about to prove them
all wrong
he entered the valorant scene as part of
faze clan and his roster was mostly made
up of retired overwatch pros
with valran's esports scene still in
diapers cory was determined to set the
record straight
that he and his teammates could beat any
player no matter what game they used to
play
there's just something about beating
these cs teams that like think that i
like
specifically me like play like stupid
that's so that's what they call it like
that's how they call it like
well at least at least that's what uh
specifically hundred thieves would say
in scrims
they would be like yo like if you rush
in the first 10 seconds of the round
we're gonna leave
faze clan's chance to finally lay the
overwatch stigma to rest came in march
2021
during the champions tour and a
challenger stage
again with marv though and there's an
open to the back side there
corey swinging hard he gets two oh
no corey three boy dre falls they're
just picking them apart one by one deep
doesn't even have enough time to get
into the flank it's a flawless for faze
the numbers are dwindling but corey
again great position here up close able
to pull out the show stopper try to hold
you up
no way they have to get back on and find
the plan baby they gonna find the kills
they're just gonna push right through
and try and stop it that's it right
there the spike goes down and faze
they clean them up make it corey nothing
discovered and this is energy trying to
starve a little bit of information of
their road but nobody expects corey to
me in the house that's
two and actually trying to play ahead of
phaser's utility right now by sneaking
in to be in its work
pretty well it's a show stopper to shop
his show
[Music]
faze blew past competitors like t1 nrg
and luminosity
to face off against 100 thieves a team
made up almost
entirely a former cs go pros if there
was ever a time for cory and his
teammates to pull together and win
this was it it was their moment to prove
that their overwatch roots weren't going
to stop them from
dominating invalorant and during the
challengers grand final
cory and his squad wipe the floor with
hundred thieves
oh no it doesn't work okay
faze have turned things around you've
got zachary who's full w
he has zero chill they spot one towards
me they know the last players on high
they're gonna try and tap despite
debating out of position it's steal
we talked about it in the pregame how
are they going to
handle an up presence when we knew it
would come in from face
bread and butter and corey he says it's
cute and all that we rely on the op
we don't need to i'm here nice shots
coming out early from baby bay
on the marshall not the off danes coming
down doing significant damage and that's
what allows cory
to absolutely punish near-sightedness
not going to affect him corey
already on the flank and they have no
idea corey doesn't
lift a little bit at the beginning there
but it's still down to one player
remaining it's ethan with the sheriff
and sure every member of faves was part
of the team's triumph
but corey's contribution with rays made
a huge difference
rory spots one up on the rafters over
towards heaven how does that work ethan
just sticks around a little too long
they still haven't secured a plant
zachary just wants to go for the swing
but it's actually baby bay to drop him
and now the round is falling apart
it's gonna be faze who go through as the
number one seed coming out
of challengers three with a big win over
100 thieves
and while challenger's results don't
definitively prove that one esports
scene is superior to another
they do show that sometimes the
stereotypes just aren't true
sometimes you have to believe what you
see with your own
eyes having this be our first win we had
something to prove and i think we all
proved ourselves that we could do it
and we are good players because we knew
we were but we just hadn't gotten
any like good success so even though the
win was for
only money and seating it still meant a
lot to us i don't think any of us really
care who we're going to go against i
think we're all confident in whatever
team we play that we're going to do what
we want to do
corey and the rest of phase may have
gotten their start in what many believe
is an easier game
but clearly they have no plans to take
it easy
and valorent thanks for watching if you
want more content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite size
videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our instagram
twitter and facebook pages